après 39 heures d'un strict couvre-feu
il est à nouveau possible de circuler
dans kiev
peu à peu les habitants ressortent de
chez eux direction pour beaucoup des
supermarchés devant lesquels comme ici
de longues files d'attentes se forme
dans ce quartier frappé par un missile
russe samedi
la fébrilité se lit sur les visages
je suis effrayé et j'espère vraiment que
les combats vont se terminer
vous pensez que l'armée russe peut venir
jusqu'ici roshan armée cool comme
oui
la nuit dernière des milliers
d'habitants encore dormi dans le métro
dans les halls de gare mais surtout dans
les sous sols des immeubles
sur quelques mètres carrés chacun tente
de s'adapter à ce quotidien bouleversé
du provisoire qui pourrait durer car
malgré la fin du couvre-feu le maire de
kiev appelle chacun à la plus grande
prudence
mais ne vous exposez pas au danger il
des fusillades ont lieu dans certains
quartiers et même aux heures autorisées
de sortie en ville qu'en cas d'absolue
nécessité
profitant du calme relatif qui règne à
kiev des centaines d'habitants ce matin
quitter la ville en voiture
certains emprunter l'autoroute m 05 qui
mène vers le sud et la ville de vassil
tive une voie de communication que les
troupes russes ont assuré ne pas prendre
pour cible
dans kiev et sa région les combats
pourraient reprendre dans les heures qui
viennent ce midi un important convoi
militaire ukrainien a été aperçue dans
les rues de la capitale